solo este sábado colombia reportó 400
muertos por kobe y 19 la cifra diaria
más alta en el país desde que se tiene
registro ella solo en total cerca de
17.000 fallecidos la situación se dan
justo cuando la nación se encamina a
reactivar otros sectores de su economía
el gobierno aprobó un piloto para darle
apertura a los bares aunque
restringiendo el consumo de licor ya hay
que reconocer también que muchos de los
países que han dado los pasos de abrir
bares se han encontrado después con
medidas que son retrocesos como no
queremos tener un retroceso lo que
queremos es empezar con el expendio de
alimentos y otro tipo de bebidas que los
bares son uno de los lugares donde menos
se puede mantener la distancia social y
donde efectivamente ahí hay mayor
evidencia de contagio entre personas
como todos sabemos el licor es uno de
los temas de los aspectos que más
y reduce la inhibición social y más de
que lo acercamos bogotá tiene cerca de
una cuarta parte de los fallecidos a
nivel nacional y grandes sectores de la
ciudad siguen en estrictas cuarentenas
en medio de este panorama la alcaldesa
claudia lópez examina un alivio en las
restricciones el lunes propondremos al
ministerio de salud del modelo de nueva
realidad que esperamos poder empezar
desde septiembre que podamos trabajar
socializar y algunos estudiar con
responsabilidad y autocuidado será la
mayor prueba de cultura ciudadana de
nuestra historia
el gobierno nacional también aprobó
planes piloto para más de 120 municipios
donde existe una moderada afectación por
kobe 19 esto permitirá reactivar
restaurantes servicios religiosos
casinos y gimnasios hoy el país es el
cuarto más afectado de américa latina'